[Music]
hey guys it's quinn here
if you appreciate my content help me out
with the youtube algorithm by clicking
the like button
thanks guys the hyperion cantos by dan
simmons takes place hundreds of years in
our future
hyperion is the name of one of the
outback worlds
found in the hegemony of man and
interstellar society
in the opening of the first book
hyperion seven pilgrims were chosen by
the church of the final atonement
to partake in the strike pilgrimage the
church of the final atonement
which was also known as the strike
church had many temples
the largest of which resided on the web
world of lusis
and there was also one on the outback
world of hyperion
the church used their bureaucratic and
political power to influence much of
what happens on hyperion
often the shrek church allowed
off-worlders to partake in the
pilgrimage
into the territory of the legendary
being known as the shrike
but the creature known as the strike
which i have covered in these videos
here
has almost never allowed anyone to
return once they have entered his domain
the church of the strike chooses the
sacrificial victims from thousands of
volunteers
the web is full of stupid depressed
people
few of these return the strike is one of
the most mysterious and feared beings in
the universe
and the opening of the series its
territory is expanding
which is a cause for concern for the
inhabitants of the hegemony
particularly because if a firecaster was
ever set
up on hyperion the strike would gain
access to the 200 or so worlds connected
in the web of hegemony planets
by farcaster teleportation technology
the strike was seemingly undefeatable
and no one knew its full potential
destructive capabilities none of the
pilgrims at the start of the hyperion
cantos
seem to know for certain why they have
been chosen to take
part in the pilgrimage but they all have
different reasons for going
as the first book goes on each of them
tells their story
explaining why they chose to volunteer
to come to hyperion
and partake in the strike pilgrimage the
pilgrims had to be approved
by both the hegemony and the church
before they were allowed to make the
voyage to hyperion
and the reasons for the specific people
chosen was never transparent
for instance does anyone here know why
he or she was chosen by the strike
church
and the all thing to go on this voyage
no one spoke
i thought not said weintraub even more
fascinating
is anyone here a member or a follower of
the church of the strike
the church of the final atonement
worshiped the being commonly called the
shrike as the lord of pain
none of the pilgrims at the beginning of
the series are actually believers in the
strike religion
the church believed that he was sent to
force humanity to atone for its sins
the strike church doctrine stated that
one day the strike would be freed from
his small territory on hyperion
and unleashed upon the human universe
they believed that this was inevitable
and when it happened all humans would be
destroyed mercilessly
at the hands of the strike as punishment
for all the sins of mankind
he was their angel of retribution from
beyond time
it was the belief of the church that
humankind was meant to die with old
earth
400 years ago they believed that the
hajira
the great exodus from the planet earth
before its destruction had been a
mistake
the time since then they believed had
been false time
androids were illegal in the hegemony
and had been for more than 100 years
but on remote outback worlds like
hyperion they were still used
though new ones had not been
manufactured for decades
the church of the final atonement
believed that androids were worthier in
spirit to mankind
they were pure creatures not bound to
original sin
as all men were they believed that when
the strike was finally unleashed upon
humanity
the androids would be spared therefore
the strike temple used androids often
the shrike temple had used androids
extensively
complying with the church of the shrike
doctrine which proclaimed that androids
were free
from original sin therefore spiritually
superior to humankind
and incidentally exempt from the
strike's terrible and inevitable
retribution
the strike temple on hyperion was the
planet's most popular tourist attraction
the central temple was an enormous
spiraling gothic-like cathedral
structure the angles and curves of the
structure gave the impression of
impossible angles and perspectives in a
very lovecraftian fashion
strike church's central temple was part
awe-inspiring cathedral
part gothic joke with its fluid
buttressed curves of stone
perma bonded to its whiskered alloy
skeleton
part esker print with its tricks of
perspective
and impossible angles part bashing
nightmare with its tunnel entrances
hidden chambers dark gardens and
forbidden sections
and more than anything else it had been
a part of hyperion's past
the strike church has many secrets which
unveil themselves as the story goes on
it is revealed eventually that they have
a connection to the techno corps
the sentient amalgamation of ai
intelligence
which had succeeded from humanity and
formed its own independent entity long
ago
the strike church itself like other
things in dan simmons books
that i have mentioned in another video
invokes the lovecraftian trope
of a cult which forms around a strange
and powerful otherworldly being
in such stories certain humans seem
drawn to this kind of worship
human beings like to believe that there
is something greater than themselves
when they are given evidence of its
existence they fall back in a way that
humans have done just about since the
beginning
they offer worship to that thing because
by ascribing intent and will to that
creature
they are attempting to make it fit into
their narrow perceptions
they are able to overlook and even
justify the true nature of that terrible
thing
because in their mind the thing is
justified in what it does
merely by virtue of what it is thank you
guys so much for watching make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinns ideas
sci-fi content
you